[Musik]
am montag zusammen hierbei zdf heute
live und ihren live stream zu aktuellen
ereignissen die korona krise beschäftigt
uns natürlich weiter und zwar in einem
maße wie wir es heute nicht für möglich
gehalten haben die bundeskanzlerin wird
sich vor der hauptstadtpresse erklären
das ist ein relativ ungewöhnlicher
vorgang erklärt sich aber aus der den
beschlüssen die vorgestern verkündet
wurden zwischen der bundeskanzlerin und
den ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
da gab es ja ein ziemlich langes treffen
und danach nach dem treffen gab es
relativ viel kritik die einen sagten es
ist nicht genug passiert das ist alles
zu wenig und nicht stringent genug die
anderen haben vor allem gesagt es ist
eine fehlende langzeitstrategie die sie
nicht sehen viel streit gab es um schuhe
öffnungen oder die frage wie lange kann
man distanz unterricht machen
die bundeskanzlerin hatte dort wohl
einen kurs vorgeschlagen der vorsah dass
erst bei 50 neu gemeldeten fällen pro
100.000 einwohner in sieben tagen die
schulen wieder in den regelbetrieb
übergehen können
das hat sich nicht durchgesetzt jetzt
bleibt es erstmal so wie es schon seit
mitte dezember ist das heißt die schulen
sollen wenn möglich distanz unterricht
anbieten und die kinder und schülerinnen
und schüler soll der schule fernbleiben
dann gab es ja die ffb zwei masken
pflicht die neu beschlossen wurde
beziehungsweise die pflicht auch zu
tragen einer medizinischen maske
erreichen auch op masken in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und in geschäften
das wurde jetzt nicht so stark
kritisiert home office ist eine weitere
maßnahme die beschlossen wurde zumindest
soll home office angeboten werden müssen
eine verordnung dazu soll heute noch aus
dem arbeitsministerium kommen aber noch
haben wir sie nicht gelesen
wir warten darauf dass die
bundeskanzlerin sich hier in der
bundespressekonferenz vor dem kollegen
an eintrifft und sich den fragen stellt
und meine kollegin nicole diekmann wird
das ganze mit uns zusammen beobachten im
hauptstadtstudio gut morgen nicole ich
habe schon mal gesagt es ist relativ
selten dass die bundeskanzlerin sich der
hauptstadtpresse stellt oder warum macht
sie das so selten
da kann man im moment nur spekulieren
aber es wäre relativ logisch wenn die
motivation dafür erstens wäre noch mal
zu erklären warum man zu diesen
beschlüssen gekommen ist für den mann
vorgestern gekommen ist denn das ganze
war im vorfeld total aufgeladen
also auch wir medien hatten tage zuvor
schon angefangen darüber zu berichten
weil aber auch einige der beteiligten
tage zuvor schon angefangen hatten
darüber zu diskutieren und da heißt das
du hast ja eben auch schon gesagt also
dafür wie sehr das hochgejazzt worden
ist ist da relativ wenig bei rumgekommen
dann gibt es eben die kritik an den
beschlüssen selbst da ist ein kernpunkt
dass man sich nicht ran betraut hat
wirklich mal anders thema home office es
gibt jetzt so jetzt eine verordnung
geben ja aber einigen dann doch wieder
zuwachs weich und da heißt es dann also
an die schulen traut man sich dann
irgendwie doch ran aber wenn es um die
wirtschaft geht da hält man sich dann
vornehm zurück dann sind ja direkt noch
am abend des gipfels erste bundesländer
ausgeschert einen voran baden
württemberg hat gesagt na ja unter
umständen öffnen wir die schulen schon
wieder zum ersten februar nicht wie
eigentlich zuvor in anwesenheit von
baden württemberg beschlossen zum 15
februar
unterm strich gibt es da doch noch eine
menge zu erklären und was auch ein thema
war im vorfeld dieses bund länder
treffen vorgestern das war das thema
müdigkeit stichwort pandemie müdigkeit
beziehungsweise corona maßnahme
möglichkeit frustration bei den leuten
die so hat das der cdu-ministerpräsident
daniel günther in schleswig-holstein
ausgedrückt die leute ein wenig
frustriert weil man sich wie er sagt
jedes mal von gipfel zu gipfel handelt
dann gibt es wieder ein paar beschlüsse
und dann trifft man sich ein paar wochen
später dann gibt es neue maßnahmen und
es gibt keine langzeit
langfriststrategie also ich könnte mir
vorstellen und das angela merkel das zum
einen noch mal heute erklären will warum
man zu diesen beschlüssen gekommen ist
ja einigen nicht reichen die anderen zu
unausgewogen sind und aber auch noch mal
versuchen will die leute zu motivieren
sich weiter an das zu halten was man
eben beschlossen hat machen und den
versuch die deutungshoheit über diese
diskussion vielleicht doch wieder ein
bisschen auf ihre seite zu ziehen
wenn ich das richtig sehe noch ganz
genau und auch ein vorwurf zu entkräften
der sie nicht nur in der korona krise
ich sehe gerade aus dem augenwinkel sie
kommt gerade reinig für den satz schnell
zu ende der ihn nicht nur in der korona
krise immer wieder mal gemacht wurde
dass sie ihre politik zu wenig erklärt
dass wir sie heute anscheinend anders
machen
gut ich sehe die bundeskanzlerin ist
eingetroffen den platz in der
bundespressekonferenz das ist muss man
noch mal kurz erklären ein verein der
hauptstadtjournalisten da dort hat
tatsächlich dieser verein das hausrecht
lädt politikerinnen und politiker ein
die sich dann dort den gesammelten
fragen der hauptstadtpresse stellen
können und die bundeskanzlerin nimmt
diese einladung heute an und wird sich
jetzt äußern wir sind gespannt und hören
zu
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz
wir begrüßen als unser gast heute die
bundeskanzlerin frau dr angela merkel
bekommen frau bundeskanzlerin
das interesse der bundeskanzlerin dieses
mal ist wie eigentlich immer bei unseren
pressekonferenzen in dieser zeit
ausgesprochen groß es gibt auch dieses
mal wie im letzten jahr bei vielen
vielen pressekonferenzen viele live
übertragungen deshalb noch mal der
hinweis den wir regelmäßig geben weil es
alle zuschauer nicht wissen
sie sind bei der bundespressekonferenz
das ist kein teil der bundesregierung
wir sind ein unabhängiger verein der
berliner parlaments journalistinnen und
journalisten deshalb werden diese
pressekonferenzen auch von journalisten
geleitet das ist eine seit jahrzehnten
geübte und bewährte tradition und wir
freuen uns dass sie sich dem heute
einmal mehr im letzten jahr waren sie
glaube ich drei mal bei uns dass sie
sich diesem auch zum beginn dieses
jahres wieder anschließen
sie haben das wort ich sag gleich noch
was zu den fragen regeln bitte frau
bundeskanzlerin ja meine damen und
herren wir befinden uns eher in einer
sehr schwierigen phase der pandemie und
das war auch der grund warum die
regierungschefinnen und die
regierungschefs des bundes und der
länder
schon am dienstag ihre beratungen
fortgesetzt haben und nicht erst wie
geplant am kommenden montag
und das ist auch der grund warum ich
heute vormittag wieder als sehr gerne
hierher gekommen bin ich möchte ihnen
meine analyse und bewertung der lage
erläutern und natürlich dann gerne auch
ihre fragen beantworten und dafür möchte
ich nicht auch bei der
bundespressekonferenz ganz herzlich
bedanken dass sie mir diese möglichkeit
einräumen
wir sind also in einer sehr schwierigen
phase der pandemie und warum ist das so
weil wir ein gespaltenes bild haben auf
der einen seite gegen gehen die
täglichen neuinfektionen zurück endlich
das sind gute nachrichten und wir müssen
endlich auch etwas weniger menschen auf
intensivstationen behandeln als das noch
vor weihnachten und über weihnachten der
fall war
auch das ist eine gute nachricht weil es
ja seit beginn der pandemie immer wieder
darum geht eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
und das ist ja nicht allein eine
medizinische frage sondern es gab und
gibt eben nicht ich habe das schon oft
gesagt wird aber hier noch mal
wiederholen
diesen gegensatz gesundheit oder
wirtschaft gesundheit oder bildung
gesundheit oder kultur was dem ziel die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zum
einen dient allen den menschen der
wirtschaft der bildung der kultur also
unserer ganzen gesellschaft und wir
können uns ja auch gar nicht oft genug
vor augen führen was wäre wenn wir mit
maßnahmen gegen das virus warten würden
bzw gewartet hätten bis die
intensivstationen voll belegt gewesen
wären dann wäre es nämlich zu spät
gewesen
und es ist deshalb sehr wichtig und sehr
ermutigend dass sich die aktuelle lage
zu entspannen beginnt das zeigt dass die
harten einschnitte die die menschen in
deutschland seit wochen auf sich nehmen
müssen sich auszuzahlen beginnen und das
zeigt im grunde dass die mühe sich lohnt
und ich kann nur einmal mehr von herzen
für die unterstützung der übergroßen
mehrheit der bürgerinnen und bürgern
danken wir wissen dass dieses virus eine
zumutung für uns alles aber ich sage zu
beginn
ich sagte zu beginn dass die pandemie
eben ein gespaltenes bild zeigt und da
gibt es die andere seite auf der anderen
seite haben wir es nämlich mit
erschreckend hohen todeszahlen zu tun
dass es furchtbar
allein heute wieder über 1000 menschen
das sind nicht einfach zahlen das sind
menschen den einsamkeit gestorben sind
das sind schicksale das sind familien
die um sie trauern und auch das müssen
wir uns immer wieder bewusst machen und
auch darüber hinaus haben wir
gegenwärtig damit zu kämpfen dass all
unsere bemühungen gegen das virus eine
gefahr
trotzdem nicht außer acht lassen können
unseren bemühungen droht eine gefahr und
wir sehen diese gefahr heute etwas
klarer als zu jahresbeginn und das ist
die mutation des virus wie sie vor allem
großbritannien und in irland aber auch
in den niederlanden in dänemark und
anderen ländern nach gewesen ist und
auch bei uns die bisherigen erkenntnisse
deuten darauf hin dass das mutierte
virus um ein vielfaches ansteckender ist
als das seit einem jahr bekannte und das
ist eine hauptursache für den gewaltigen
anstieg der infektionszahlen in irland
und england ist bei uns ist dieses
mutierte virus wie gesagt auch schon
nachgewiesen aber es ist nicht dominant
jedenfalls bis jetzt nicht und trotzdem
müssen wir die von dieser mutation
aussehende gefahr sehr ernst nehmen das
kann ich jedenfalls uns allen nur raten
wir müssen die ausbreitung dieser
mutation so weit wie möglich
verlangsamen
und das heißt ganz konkret wir dürfen
nicht warten bis die gefahr bei uns auch
greifbarer wird sich also dann in den
täglichen infektionszahlen niederschlägt
da wäre es zu spät um eine dritte welle
der pandemie und gegebenenfalls eine
noch heftigere als jemals zuvor zu
verhindern
wir können das noch verhindern und das
hat unsere beratungen mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten letzte woche
vorgestern geleitet es ist noch etwas
zeit um der gefahr die in diesen
mutierten virus steckt vorzubeugen es
geht also bei all den maßnahmen die wir
vorgestern beschlossen haben um vorsorge
deshalb haben bund und länder
zusätzliche maßnahmen und
einschränkungen beschlossen die den
rückgang der infektionszahlen in
deutschland noch einmal deutlich
beschleunigen sollen
bevor sich eben das mutierte virus noch
weiter ausbreitet und dies wird auch
heute abend bei der video konferenz der
staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union ein wichtiges thema
sein um nicht zu sagen im mittelpunkt
stehen es geht wird um die mutation
gehen es wird darum gehen wie wir mit
möglichst gleichwertige massnahmen
in der gesamten europäischen union diese
ausbreitung bekämpfen
denn wir sind epidemiologisch betrachtet
als europäische union ein gebiet und es
wird auch um das sequenzieren gehen also
um einen klaren überblick über die
verbreitung des mutierten virus zu
bekommen und es wird um das impfen und
die verschiedenen facetten dabei gehen
wir handeln also aus vorsorge für unser
land wir handeln aus vorsorge für die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
und damit auch aus vorsorge für
wirtschaft arbeitswelt bildung und
kultur
die unter zu verhindernden aber
gegebenenfalls explosionsartig
gestiegenen infektionszahlen noch weit
höhere krankenzahlen und schweren
schaden hervorbringen wurden oder ist
man kann es auch im umkehrschluss sagen
alles dient dem ziel in diesem jahr die
partie in den griff zu bekommen und
schließlich dann auch zu überwinden und
das ist der punkt an dem ich jetzt nicht
auf ihre fragen freue
danke und an diesen fragen mangels nicht
glaubt jede ihrer im saal hat sich schon
gemeldet also ich wer zwischendrin noch
mal handzeichen brauchen und ich muss
jetzt schon darauf hinweisen dass
wahrscheinlich nicht jede frage gestellt
werden kann denn wir haben in dieser
zeit in allen presse pressekonferenzen
aus infektiologen gründen einen
zeitrahmen von etwa einer stunde da
werden wir zum ende kommen aus diesen
gründen weil wir jetzt zu dieser
pressekonferenz jeden möglichen platz
auch besetzt haben bitte ich sie aus den
infektion infektiologen gründen auch
beim frage stellen die masken auf zu
behalten
es gibt wie immer externe fragen mathis
feldhoff der vorsitzende der
bundespressekonferenz wird diese fragen
zwischendrin auch einbringen und ich
erinnere auch noch mal daran dass die
regel heißt eine frage und dann
gegebenenfalls dazu eine nachfrage wir
beginnen mit herrenlosen lange und
format meyer
herrenlose wollte ich ihnen hat gesehen
ja dann wenn sie vor gruppen müssen
fängt ja lange an
dann rutschen sie der wahl vor bitte
selber angriffen sechs jahren geeignet
und da maßnahmen vorgeschlagen
ich glaube dass wir unter dem strich
immer beschlüsse gefasst haben die wir
gemeinsam gefasst haben da gibt es immer
wieder auch unterschiedliche bewertungen
aber dass man kann man nicht sagen
die länder und der bund das ist nicht
richtig und entspricht der sachlage
nicht wir haben vieles abzuwägen und ich
schätze diese zusammenarbeit auch wenn
sie manchmal mühselig ist auch wenn sie
uns viel zeit kostet weil sie zum
schluss ergebnisse bringt die dann auch
von allen getragen werden und das ist
glaube ich das was die menschen im lande
auch von uns erwarten wenn es sozusagen
verdruss vielleicht manchmal gibt bei
den bürgerinnen und bürgern dann hat das
auch etwas zu tun wenn wir mit
unterschiedlichen stimmen sprechen
deshalb ist mein ansinnen als
bundeskanzlerin wirklich möglichst viel
gleich krank hier zu haben
und da wird vieles von den ländern ja
überhaupt erst umgesetzt muss
durchgesetzt werden bis auf die
kommunale ebene wir sind ein toller
start und ich kann nur sagen ich schätze
diese zusammenarbeit auch wenn sie nicht
immer völlig einfach ist aber das ist
teil der politik ich habe selten etwas
erlebt koalitionsausschuss ausschüsse
auf der bundesebene sind auch nicht
einfach oder ressort abstimmung das ist
halt unsere unser beruf los dann fordert
meyer
die zustimmung wegen schwieriger
naja ich glaube es gibt schon ein sehr
großes bedürfnis auch von mir als
bundeskanzlerin zu wissen was mich
leitet und was uns bei unseren maßnahmen
leitet und da man jetzt ja auch sonst
nicht so viel umher fahren kann und in
täglichen reden von denen wir sonst
manchmal 234 gehalten haben das immer
wieder auch sagen können ist es eine
eine fügung dass es die
bundespressekonferenz gibt und man ab
und an wir auf fragen antworten kann die
sie ja auch aufnehmen aus der
bevölkerung und ist es doch ganz klar
ich habe eben auch noch mal gesagt dass
diese pandemie ist eine
jahrhundertkatastrophe
im sinne einer naturkatastrophe und
diese pandemie wird mit recht von allen
als eine zumutung empfunden
und wenn zumutungen sehr lange dauern
dann werden sie immer schwerer auch zu
bewältigen das gilt jeden so und wenn
ich an die einschränkungen denke die
eltern mit ihren kindern jetzt
durchleben
wenn ich an das denke was lehrerinnen
und lehrer und kita erzieherin leisten
wenn sie notbetreuung oder nicht mit
präsenzunterricht aber immerhin sich um
die kinder kümmern im distanz lernen
dass doch alles riesige herausforderung
wenn ich an menschen denke die
einzelhandelsgeschäfte führen oder
restaurantbesitzer oder die
kulturschaffenden die gerne etwas
einbringen würden und mit soviel
begrenzungen und beschränkungen leben
müssen dann wäre es doch ganz
verwunderlich wenn da nicht wirklich
auch die geduld auf eine extrem harte
probe gestellt wird und das ist
uns doch auch bewusst und trotzdem haben
wir die verantwortung mit dieser lage
die keiner von uns herbeigeführt hat
sondern die sozusagen gekommen ist
verantwortlich umzugehen und meine für
meine prognose war ja eh dass je länger
das dauert
und gerade der winter jetzt noch mal
sehr sehr schwer wird und an den nerven
von uns allen zerrt aber ich glaube wir
haben mehr etwas wenn man sich mal die
zeit der spanischen grippe zum beispiel
anschaut vor mehr als 100 jahren
da haben wir doch etwas was uns im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in eine
doch trotz aller schwierigkeit viel
bessere lage versetzt wir haben jetzt
schon impfstoffe und wir wissen wie wir
den weg aus dieser krise finden können
und wir haben sogar impfstoffe die
selbst bei mutationen des virus relativ
schnell diese m rna impfstoffe angepasst
werden könnte ist ein riesen erfolg der
forschung und ich meine wir haben nicht
immer nur in höchsten tönen gesprochen
von menschen die medikamente entwickeln
aber in diesem falle zeigt sich doch
dass da etwas ganz wunderbares gelungen
ist was im übrigen ja nicht in zehn
monaten entwickelt wurde sondern wo
hinter 20 jahre forschung liegen die wir
noch gar nicht gesehen haben und wo wir
ja auch nicht wussten was man daraus
wird also sind wir bei allem bei aller
bedrückung doch in einer lage die uns
deutlich unterscheidet von pandemien die
vor 100 und mehr jahren die menschheit
ergriffen haben und das wollen wir ja
dann auch nutzen aber es ist eine
schwere zeit da gibt es überhaupt nichts
drumherum zu reden dann marc meier und
dann havelberg links
ich sehe ja wie man muss erstens sagen
dass wir im augenblick einen impfstoff
haben mit beim tag der logistik auch
nicht ganz einfach zu verarbeiten ist
mit minus 70 grad kühlungssystem das
heißt gerade bei diesem impfstoff ist es
nicht ganz einfach sofort auch die allen
bereichen der welt zu impfen
dennoch haben wir hier eine
riesenaufgabe vor uns ich meine wir in
deutschland diskutieren mit recht
darüber wie knapp der impfstoff am
anfang jetzt hier bei uns ist aber ich
habe auch telefonate mit kollegen aus
anderen bereichen und die haben
natürlich eine große sehnsucht danach
überhaupt einen impfstoff zu sehen
wir unterstützen cobox diese
internationale initiative und haben uns
da auch finanziell beteiligt das reicht
aber nicht allein finanzielle sondern
gar wie diese im wallis führt ja die
verhandlungen für cobox das auch jetzt
sehr schnell in ärmeren ländern
impfstoffe bereit gestellt werden können
und soweit ich informiert bin sind
sowohl bei
bei beyoncé kaiser als auch bei
astrazeneca die verhandlungen doch sehr
intensiv im gange und ich hoffe dass wir
da relativ schnell auch aussagen
bekommen dass hier auch besser geimpft
werden kann
herr sattelberger blank und die
kolleginnen rechts hinter herren blank
ja ich habe das gelesen ich will darauf
hinweisen dass bei uns die länder das ja
entscheiden gerade auch in gebieten mit
hoher incidents kennen wir auch das
instrument der sperrstunde bayern hat
jetzt schon viele wochen eine
ausgangssperre
baden württemberg auch sachsen auch das
heißt also das ist auch bei uns
gebraucht wir haben da keine ganz
einheitliche bundesweite situation weil
wir auch sehr unterschiedliche
situationen haben wir haben in bremen
der inzidenz von 77 und oder knapp 80
und in anderen gebieten weit über 200
das heißt also das instrument ist
geläufig in deutschland es ist ein
harter eingriff das ist ganz klar dass
darüber auch diskutiert wird und
parlamentarisch beraten wird aber die
närrische regierung hat ja auch die
begründung geliefert und das hat auch
mit der mutation zu tun und bei diese
mutierten virus geht es ja darum der das
ist da das können wir jetzt nicht mehr
weg kriegen da geht es jetzt nur noch
darum wie können wir seine ausbreitung
verlangsame
um dann in eine bessere jahreszeit zu
kommen wo witterungsbedingt
die gegebenheiten etwas besser sind die
sind auch nicht so viel besser dass es
sich gar nicht mehr verbreitet aber
etwas besser das was wir selber aus dem
frühjahr und aus dem sommer und mit dem
impfen weiter vorangekommen zu sein das
ist die sozusagen die dahinterliegende
abwägung die wir zu treffen haben
ob das gelingt muss man sehen deshalb
wird auch heute beim europäischen rat
das thema sequenzieren wo die
niederlande sehr gut sind wo wir jetzt
aufholen müssen in deutschland eine
rolle spielen dass wir alle mindestens
fünf prozent der fälle sequenzieren
damit wir einen überblick darüber haben
wie weit die verbreitung des virus
bereits ist lang habe ich andere auf der
anderen seite geht das sie müssen nicht
sehen können weil ich sie sehen kann
dann gehört das steht eben ein bisschen
bei anderen debatte stehen sehr stark
haben die teils werte und jedesmal cdu
chef und dessen leben
die aufgaben profitieren kann werden
sich künftige verteilung ist passt das
glaube ich überhaupt nicht also erst
einmal habe ich natürlich armin laschet
gratuliert zweitens ist er
ministerpräsident des größten
bundeslandes in der bundesrepublik
deutschland und drittens ist es doch
ganz klar meine amtszeit ist die dieser
legislaturperiode und da bin ich die
bundeskanzlerin und habe und trage die
verantwortung und die muss sich
wahrnehmen und da gibt es auch überhaupt
gar keinen unterschied zwischen der
sicht von armin laschet und mir
und dann gibt es und das wird natürlich
mit namen dem wahlkampf immer stärker
dann auch sichtbar werden
dann gibt es die frage was passiert in
den nächsten vier jahren und welche
partei hat welche pläne und über diese
frage was passiert in den nächsten vier
jahren entscheidet die cdu mit der zeit
an der spitze der cdu steht armin
laschet gemeinsam mit der csu das heißt
in diese ganze frage welche
entwicklungen will man beschleunigen
bekräftigen welche neuen akzente will
man setzen werde ich natürlich wenn ich
gefragt werde mit einem ratschlag
eingehen aber die beschlüsse die
entscheidung dieses zusammenführen der
partei für diese programmatik das
passiert alles dann unter der ägide der
neuen cdu führung und damit glaube ich
ist die arbeitsteilung gegeben und das
kann und wird sehr gut funktionieren die
kolleginnen hinter haben wann ich habe
ihren namen hat mich präsent und dann
herr rinke unter jungen und auch den
menschen um das vielleicht noch
hinzuzufügen auch den bürgerinnen und
bürgern wird das immer klarer bewusst
werden dass ich jetzt meine arbeit zu
machen habe dass ich sie mit freude
machen natürlich weil ich mich für diese
legislaturperiode entschieden habe aber
es wird ja niemals eine wahl aus
dankbarkeit für irgendetwas geben weil
eine bundeskanzlerin gerade gut
oder nicht so gute umfragewerte hat das
leitet mich ähnlich und darf mich auch
nicht leiten bei der pandemie aber die
menschen wollen wissen wie geht's weiter
und ich sag mal diese pandemie wird ja
schwierige spuren hinterlassen im
wirtschaftsleben in der frage wie geht
es weiter mit der bildung der kinder
wenn jetzt viele wochen keinen
unterricht hatten in der frage wie ist
das mit dem föderalen aufbau wie können
wir kommunen ertüchtigen
wie können wir die bundeskompetenz haben
in der frage wie ordnen wir uns
international ein
und dann wird immer weiter in den
vordergrund rücken was erwartet uns in
den nächsten vier jahren und das ist
auch ganz normal und richtig so rinke
beim regierung zu tun
[Musik]
er ist als minister haben sie
garantieren bundesbürger also erstmal
möchte ich dazu folgendes sagen dass wir
am tag der zulassung bereits produzierte
impfstoffe haben
das ist ein novum das hat es in der
medizingeschichte glaube ich selten
gegeben dass das medikament bereits
produziert war bevor es zugelassen wurde
und das ging nur in einem sehr guten
zusammenwirken von staaten
genehmigungsbehörden und unternehmen
weil man ja so eine rollierende
zulassung gemacht hat weil man erlaubt
hat das schon bestellt produziert werden
durfte und weil man dann auch schon in
der lage war dabei wir auch gewisse
haftungen übernommen haben denn es kann
ja auch sein jemand bekommt keine
zulassung und das sollte die unternehmen
nicht in die insolvenz führen
zweitens wir haben ja gewusst dass wir
am anfang nicht zu viel impfstoff haben
werden wie wir jetzt im sommer haben
werden und was immer diskutiert wird ist
die frage wie viel impfstoff habt ihr
bestellt das ist überhaupt nicht ehrlich
gesagt interessant interessant ist nur
wie viel impfstoff bekommen wir im
ersten quartal also im vierten quartal
2020 im ersten quartal 2021 im zweiten
quartal und nach menschlichem ermessen
haben wir dann im dritten quartal
ausreichend impfstoff um wahrscheinlich
auch schon welchen abgeben zu können
was kann die bundesregierung garantieren
ich betreibe keine produktionswerke für
impfstoffe also kann ich nicht
garantieren dass die produktion so läuft
sondern wir können nur alles tun und das
haben wir getan
zu unterstützen dass die
impfstoffproduktion stattfinden kann
und um auch wenn notwendig erweiterte
kapazitäten bereitzustellen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat von
august an mit bei montech gemeinsam weit
vor der zulassung als kein mensch wusste
war es bei phasen drei herauskommt dass
die berg in marburg in den blick
genommen es ist die genehmigung erteilt
worden die betriebsgenehmigung liegt
bereits vor
und das wird die produktion erweitern
jetzt hat sich pfizer entschieden im
augenblick wird sehr sehr wenig in
europäischen als in europäischen
eigentum beschäftigt wird befindlichen
fabriken produziert biontech ist ein
start-up bug ist keine produktionsfirma
und bei intercard den klugen schritt
gemacht sich mit einem anerkannten
internationalen pharmakonzernen zu
verbünden um die phase 3 möglichst
schnell durchzuführen weil das
logistisch für ein start up überhaupt
nicht möglich ist 40 tausend probanden
auf der welt zu finden in irgendwelchen
regionen wo sehr viele infektionen
auftreten und dann wird bisher im
wesentlichen in zwei anlagen produziert
und die pfizer anlagen in amerika
während für amerika genutzt und die
faser anlage in europa insgesamt fünf
stationen für belgien das ist der
weltweite vertrieb außerhalb der
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
vater hat sich jetzt entschieden was ja
nun wirklich nicht zu beanstanden ist
seine produktion hochzufahren und muss
dazu umbauten vornehmen falls steht aber
weiterhin dazu dass im ersten quartal
die versprochenen impfstoffe also bei
uns herr kaiser die versprochenen
vertraglich gesicherten impfstoffe
kommen
jetzt haben sich die tages lieferung
verändert und die kommissionspräsidentin
unserer vornherein und ich sehe das
genauso hat absolut recht dass wir jetzt
natürlich aufpassen müssen dass wir
nicht medizinisch in die bedrängung
kommen weil die zweite impfstoffdosis
natürlich gegeben werden muss in einem
bestimmten zeitrahmen und darauf muss
man achten und das ist auch das was wir
erwarten aber es kann natürlich immer
wieder vorkommen dass der erhöhung der
produkte der produktion auch
umbaumaßnahmen stattfinden müssen so
jetzt erwarten wir also und
die für uns versprochenen 88 millionen
dosen von bionic für das erste quartal
damit rechnen wir und ich habe nichts
gehört dass das nicht stattfinden kann
dennoch muss man sehen ich habe wir
haben uns neulich innerhalb der
bundesregierung auch mit vizekanzler und
mit peter altmaier und jens spahn mal
angeschaut was für eine lieferkette an
der erstellung eines solchen impfstoffs
dranhängen und wir werden alles tun um
diese lieferkette zu zu sichern
denn da brauchen sie kochsalzlösung das
hört sich trivial an aber wenn die
plötzlich gas oder irgendwelche
glasfläschchen nicht da sind oder etwas
anderes nicht dann haben wir ein problem
und es ist alles sehr sehr klar geregelt
und es arbeiten alle mit hochdruck daran
und wir haben ja auch immer wieder diese
unternehmen unterstützt und haben gesagt
wir unterstützen alles also wir können
garantieren dass die unternehmen die
unterstützung bekommen die produktion
selbst kann ich nicht garantieren
und das zweite ist ich kann auch nicht
garantieren wie viele menschen sich
impfen lassen
das liegt in der entscheidung der
bürgerinnen und bürger herdenimmunität
erfordert eine bestimmte zahl von
geimpften menschen und je nach
aggressivität des virus variiert das
auch zwischen 60 und etwas mehr prozent
wir haben das jetzt keinen impfstoff für
kinder
das heißt die unter 18-jährigen sind
können noch nicht geimpft werden da an
den impfstoffen für kinder wird
geforscht das ist ja auch vernünftig
dass man sich erstmal um die älteren
gekümmert hat und dann werden wir nach
wenn alles so ist wie uns die
unternehmen jetzt zugesagt haben dann
werden wir nach dem zweiten quartal
schon deutlich viel mehr menschen
geimpft haben und wir werden so ist
unser ziel und wenn die zulassung auch
so eintreten kann man das schaffen dann
werden wir auch bis ende des sommers
habe ich gesagt das wiederhole ich hier
gerne auch jedem bürger ein ins angebot
gemacht haben das ende des sommers ist
beim kalendarisch der einundzwanzigste
september damit wir uns da nicht weiter
streifen aber dass das können wir sagen
denn astrazeneca eine zulassung bekommt
was ja vielleicht nächste woche passiert
und wenn ja wenn sonst nichts passiert
ich meine wir müssen jetzt gucken die
mutationen sind natürlich wieder an
stellen andere anforderungen bis jetzt
hat man den eindruck dass britische
virus behindert und beeinträchtigt die
wirkung des impfstoffes nicht aber das
virus weiter mutieren und dann kann es
natürlich auch passieren dass bestimmte
impfstoffe wieder nachjustiert werden
müssen also all das kann ich ihnen nicht
versprechen aber ich kann ihnen
versprechen dass wir alles tun um mit
schnellstmöglich an diese impfstoffe zu
kommen im übrigen will ich dazu noch ein
punkt sagen je mehr fälle wir haben auf
der welt also auch in deutschland und in
europa umso größer ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit von mutationen das
heißt schon aus dem grund mutationen zu
verhindern ist es sehr sinnvoll die zahl
der fälle möglichst klein zu halten denn
wenn es virus nur in geringer zahl
existiert fällt ihm auch nicht so viel
ein bezüglich der mutation und
mutationen sind etwas womit man
wirklich immer rechnen muss leider und
diese hier ist es mutation passieren
permanent aber diese hier ist qualitativ
offensichtlich und nicht zum guten im
sinne der gebremst teilt der krankheit
also ich hab ja vor der amtseinführung
bereits kontakt aufgenommen jetzt dann
habe ich keinen kontakt aufgenommen
es gibt einfach mit präsident biden
einen viel breiteren raum von
politischer übereinstimmung die als wenn
sie sich allein die executive orders die
gestern unterzeichnet wurden anschauen
dann sehen sie doch dass wir in der whu
wieder zusammenarbeiten können dass er
im pariser klimaabkommen wieder
zusammenarbeiten können dass wir über
fragen der migration wahrscheinlich eine
ähnliche meinung haben und wir wissen
aber auch dass mit dem amtsantritt eines
neuen amerikanischen präsidenten
wer jetzt nicht sozusagen nur noch auf
politische übereinstimmung rechnen
können sondern dass es auch diskussionen
geben wird wie wir die dinge gut für
beide länder machen
joe biden vertritt die interessen der
vereinigten staaten von amerika ich
vertrete die interessen der
bundesrepublik deutschland und es wird
ja allerorten auch richtigerweise gesagt
europa wird insgesamt mehr verantwortung
übernehmen müssen das gilt nicht nur
militärisch sondern das gilt auch
diplomatischen bereich und in vielen
anderen dingen aber die gute nachricht
ist ja wir in deutschland sind dazu
bereit und die europäische union ist
dazu auch bereit aber die zusammenarbeit
beruht einfach wieder auf einem
breiteren fundament gemeinsamer
herr jung herfried der schule noch und
dann nehmen wir mal fragen von außen
rein und ich habe auch gesehen dass noch
viele wortmeldungen im saal sind bitter
wie stehen sie zur großstadt maßnahmen
vroni ich würde es ist in dem ort musik
aufgenommen oder ins mark
[Musik]
die deutsche wirtschaft zur verfügung
gestellt werden aber es ist auch mal
nicht
[Musik]
kostenlose masten für ja erstens die no
go it strategie geht ja davon aus dass
man das virus so weit wie möglich
eindämmt und die muss man sich so
vorstellen wie unsere situation im
sommer war im sommer hatten wir das man
erinnert sich fast gar nicht mehr dran
aber im sommer hatten der instanzen
lange zeit unter 5 unter 5 und die
wissenschaftler die diese no go it
strategie vertreten sagen da sollten wir
wieder hinkommen
denn dann kann das leben am freiesten
stattfindet kann immer noch nicht ganz
frei stattfinden wissen wir ja auch was
für restriktionen hatten aber es kann
wirtschaftlich künstlerisch
bildungsmäßig ziemlich frei stattfinden
jetzt ist die frage wie kommen wir
runter mit unseren instanzen wir haben
immer die 50 grenze gehabt da wird dann
gesagt ja die ist ja frei erfunden diese
15 incident stammt sie werden sich
vielleicht erinnern daher dass wir
überlebt haben wann können die
gesundheitsämter wieder die kontakte
nachverfolgen
unstrittig ist bei unter 10 können sie
die kontakte super nachverfolgen deshalb
konnten wir diesen zustand ja auch so
lange halten
die kritische frage ist jetzt und das
ist vielleicht der unterschied zwischen
unserem praktischen politischen
herangehen und dem der no go it
strategie wenn wir jetzt wir sind jetzt
heute bei 119 instruments nach dem
robert-koch-institut jetzt gehen wir
runter wir wollten unter 50 kommen und
dann haben wir ausgerechnet was könnte
die mittlere leistungsfähigkeit eines
gesundheitsamtes sein damit man die
kontakte nachvollzieht und daraus
entsteht die 50 nicht aus irgendeiner
wissenschaftlichen grundlage
wenn jetzt die das wird die politische
diskussion sein wenn wir unter 50 sind
dann werden
wird man wissen dass man noch kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen mehrere wochen länger
als zwei drei vier wochen länger braucht
um wirklich unter zehn zu kommen
das wird bedeuten dass man weitere harte
restriktionen bezüglich
ladenschließungen bezüglich schule
einschränkungen zum weitermachen wird
und dann kommt die politik die abwägen
muss wenn ich doch denke ich könnte die
kontakt nachverfolgen schaffen lasse ich
jetzt weitere drei wochen ganz harten
restriktionen zu um unter diesen zehn zu
kommen oder nicht und das muss politisch
politisch diskutiert werden wir haben
jetzt gesagt kontakt nachverfolgung ist
für uns der punkt aber wir müssen im
kopf haben
ich habe mir die kurven vom herbst noch
mal angeguckt als wir einmal bei 25
jahren hat es noch zehn tage dauerte
ungefähr jetzt sagen 11 oder 12 09 10
tage bevor wir bei 5 das heißt sie
kommen dann sehr schnell in eine in eine
sehr exponentielle entwicklung das heißt
dass man sagen ja unsere beschlüsse
wir müssen wieder auf die kontakt
nachverfolgung kommen und wir müssen
unsere gesundheitsämter doppelt und
dreifach ertüchtigen deshalb auch
digitale kontakt nachverfolgung und
womit wir uns da alles umschlagen
sommers und dem ist und was kennen sie
alles damit wir dieses griff behalten
leichter im griff zu weiten ist es
selbstverständlich unter 10
aber wir sind nicht nur für diese frage
epidemiologie verantwortlich sondern
auch für die frage wie lange können wir
noch welche einschränkungen
rechtfertigen so das ist die die sparte
dann was du machst mir anbelangt wir
haben jetzt für 34 millionen menschen
unter anderem auch sicherlich sehr viele
hartz 4 empfänger oder
grundsicherungsempfänger ball für alle
über 60 jährigen
die ffb zwei masken für den winter zur
verfügung stellt wir haben von den
fachärzten die dringende bitte bekommen
nicht nur sp2 masken zu empfehlen
sondern auch medizinische masken
insgesamt weil es hier verschiedene
betrachtungen auch gibt von den
fachärzten
ich sag mal so wenn die wenn die gesamte
situation jetzt noch sehr lange
anhält ich kann es jetzt nicht sagen wie
lange wir das jetzt noch brauchen da
müssen wir natürlich auch darüber
nachdenken ob wir an der stelle noch mal
helfen müssen oder nicht
im augenblick haben wir das noch nicht
diskutiert aber wenn so wie wir für 34
millionen was gemacht haben wenn das
jetzt über wochen geht mit der
medizinischen massen pflicht wird das
sicherlich ein thema aus der diskussion
bleiben eher fried und der schule und
dann externe fragen
[Musik]
die schwieriger alles ist also bedauernd
wo ich das nicht die entscheidung wieder
zu kandidieren die mir schwer gefallen
ist und aber dich dann getroffen habe
und ich habe ja ihnen auch oft erzählt
dass ich manchmal lange auf eine
entscheidung
um kaum aber wenn ich sie getroffen habe
dann auch zu ihr stehe diese
entscheidung bedauere ich natürlich
nicht weil politik und das ist ja auch
das faszinierende daran besteht dass sie
oft morgens ins büro kommen und nicht
wissen wie der abend aussieht und dass
sie ein jahr beginnen und sich nicht
vorstellen können was in diesem jahr
passiert und so konnte man sich im jahr
2015 zur silvesteransprache nicht
vorstellen was uns mit der migration an
aufgabe gestellt wird und so konnte ich
mir jahre silvesteransprache 2007 nicht
vorstellen dass wir in eine wahnsinnige
finanzkrise hineinschlittern und jetzt
ist eben diese pandemie da und politiker
ist mit dem was sozusagen die realität
mit sich bringt möglichst gut zum wohle
des deutschen volkes darauf haben wir
uns ein jahr geleistet umzugehen und das
ist manchmal anstrengend aber das ist
einfach auch das was den reiz ausmacht
dass sie flexibel reagieren müssen dass
sich auf die situation einstellen müssen
ich hatte mir jetzt auch gedacht wir
kommen mit der inzidenz runter wir haben
bestimmte maßnahmen so jetzt kommt am 15
januar oder wann hat man anfang des
jahres hat man gehört plötzlich
großbritannien mutiertes virus plötzlich
ist die lage eine ganz andere und das
vielleicht wichtigste ist sich nicht
sozusagen in der politik auf den einmal
getroffen gefundenen fahrrad
zurückzuziehen und das habe ich mir vor
14 tagen beschlossen das muss ja jetzt
durchziehen sondern immer wieder klug
die lage
analysieren unsere fragen muss sich was
verändern und das ist die aufgabe und
das macht mir freude
also da bedaure ich nichts so und das
ist aber fordert und das was bleibt ist
das ich glaube ich bis jetzt der aufgabe
gerecht geworden bin aber das ist jetzt
sozusagen eine zeit ist in der man
unendlich viel über ganz viele andere
sachen nachdenken kann würde ich jetzt
nicht behaupten
wichtig ist natürlich dass wir trotzdem
an einigen stellen mit unserer agenda
vorankommen aber die korona pandemie hat
ja auch schwächen aufgezeigt die wir
eigentlich schon kannten also ich sag
mal wenn man so ein projekt hat wie das
online zugangs gesetz oder so was sie
glaube ich alle in seiner bedeutung noch
nicht so 100 prozent würdigen aber es
wird kein vorwurf sein ich sage nur das
sind so sachen mit dem wir uns immer
beschäftigen die ihr eines tages damals
die beziehung zwischen bürger und staat
verändern sollen das ist ja noch
dringlicher digitale lernplattform sind
noch dringlicher obwohl sie bei der
schule im wesentlichen von den ländern
er gestaltet werden also es ist ein ganz
breites portfolio was ich eben nicht nur
mit impfstoffherstellung befasst sondern
was tief in die frage der
digitalisierung geht was die frage der
europäischen zusammenarbeit anbelangt
wir lernen ja auch ganz viel über europa
wir sind epidemiologisch ein gebiet
inklusive der schweiz und ländern die
nicht zur europäischen union hören
der westliche balkan ist da genauso wie
anderes und wir alle anderen
mitgliedstaaten der eu zum beispiel und
die schweiz auch und was muss europa
leisten was erwarten die bürgerinnen und
bürger plötzlich haben sie erwartet dass
wir natürlich irgendwie sowohl über das
grenzregime entscheiden aber eigentlich
auch dass alle sich dem gleichen ziel
verpflichtet fühlen
zum beispiel die die fälle
runterzubringen meinetwegen bis 50
incidents pro 100000 einwohner und
sieben tage so also von der europa
politik bis hin zum verhältnis
innerhalb des föderalismus steht jetzt
vieles der debatte ist also eine sehr
spannende zeit ich konnte die aufgabe
bewältigen aber es ist verdammt
sodann habe jetzt höheren schule und
dann fragen schon außen jeden tag glaube
ich mache niemand 100 prozent alles
richtig aber bei der impfstoff
zustellung finde ich dass wir das
menschenmögliche getan haben und ich
finde vor allen dingen es richtig es
wird ja viel diskutiert dass wir uns für
eine europäische initiative entschieden
haben denn ich glaube dass es ganz ganz
furchtbar wäre wenn wir zwar in
deutschland uns impfen lassen könnten
aber in anderen ländern vor allen dingen
auch kleineren ländern die verhandlungs
logistik vielleicht gar nicht da gewesen
wäre und es würde uns auch in ganz
europa überhaupt nicht helfen denn
einige games sind andere nicht geimpft
sind gerade jetzt in der anfangszeit ist
würde ich hätte es auch für sehr
befremdlich gefunden wenn andere große
und auch sehr erfahrene
verhandlungsführer nämlich zum beispiel
frankreich italien spanien wenn wir da
auf der internationalen szene sozusagen
uns gegenseitig ausgesprochen hätten ob
wir da besser weggekommen werden das
weiß ich nicht das kann man überhaupt
nicht sagen
es wird ja manchmal so getan eine
biotech hat den impfstoff entwickelt und
jetzt ist das unser impfstoff biontech
arbeitet mit pfizer zusammen pfizer ist
eine internationale firma und jede
internet jede pharma firma die einen
internationalen markt hat wird niemals
ein gebiet bevorzugen grandios es sei
dann
es gibt so sich in spezial akte wie in
den vereinigten staaten von amerika aber
wir haben gar keine bis jetzt großartige
europäische produktionskapazität in
unserer eigenen hand
also ich halte den europäischen ansatz
für richtig ich glaube dass wir das klar
war dass man am anfang nicht so viel
impfstoff hat sie nach ein paar monaten
ich verstehe die ungeduld es gibt
überhaupt keinen grund insbesondere auf
biontech in irgendeiner weise kritik zu
üben
das sind menschen die arbeiten tag und
nacht ich möchte mit den scheinen und
seiner frau gesprochen
das kann man das überhaupt nicht
vorstellen da haben keinen tag frei
meine diese firma dieser dieser inhaber
herr schein hat am 24
januar des jahres 2020 erkannt dass eine
pandemie kommt und hat seine gesamte
forschungsarbeit um gelenkt von einem
tag auf den anderen
davon profitieren wir heute was wollen
wir jetzt noch rummeckern und ich bin
die europäische union hat getan was sie
konnte und es geht nicht um die summen
und bestellung sie sehen ja wenn marburg
eröffnet wird das neue werk kann frau
spontan einen sofort für das zweite
quartal nochmal 75 millionen dosen für
die ganze europäische union sichern aber
nur wenn das werk in morro da ist und
für das werk in marburg haben wir uns
mit aller kraft eingesetzt
und deshalb ist vollkommen irrelevant
auf 1 400 800 millionen dosen wenn die
im vierten quartal 2021 kommen sind sie
für die frage wer bei uns gehen wird
nicht mehr relevant jetzt das thema der
altenheime oder auch der älteren
menschen ich finde es richtig dass wir
sie zuerst impfen
und ich will ihnen auch ganz offen sagen
mir bricht das herz wenn ich sehe wie
viele menschen dort auch in einsamkeit
ich habe es am anfang gesagt gestorben
sind und wie das fern von der familie
ist und deshalb tun wir auch alles wir
versuchen jedenfalls alles dass
möglichst wenig passiert aber es ist
sehr viel passiert und wie gesagt das
ist emotional auch für mich extrem
schwierig mathis feldhoff hat einige
fragen von außen gesammelt bitte
[Musik]
also wir haben gesagt dass es wichtig
ist dass wir auch eine öffnung strategie
haben denn wir können natürlich am 15
februar oder wann immer wir unter 50
incident sind nicht wieder alles auf
machen sondern wir müssen natürlich
darauf wieder prioritäten setzen und
eine priorität für mich ist ganz klar
dass zuerst kitas und schulen wieder
geöffnet werden müssen
wir müssen ja ganz vorsichtig sein dass
wir nicht das erleben was in vielen
ländern passiert man macht einen harten
lockdown man öffnet und man öffnet zu
viel
und dann hat man sozusagen die das
ergebnis dass man ganz schnell wieder am
exponentiellen wachstum ist und was in
großbritannien passiert ist ist ja das
ist ja das was uns so bedenklich stimmt
und was wir beachten müssen
dort gab es einen lock down ziemlich
streng nicht mehr als sechs personen und
viele schließung aber die schulen waren
auf und die kitas im november bis anfang
dezember und dann hat man sehr schnell
vieles aufgemacht und plötzlich hat man
nicht bemerkt dass dieses mutierte virus
sich sehr viel schneller ausgebreitet
hat und dann ist in diesem aufmachen
die fallzahl für das alte die ruß
gestiegen aber es ist mit einer sechs-
bis achtmal höhere in bayern das sind
die ist das neue virus gestiegen und das
hatte man nicht vorausgesehen deshalb
weil wir wissen dass das britische virus
hier ist muss jeder öffnungs strategie
sehr vorsichtig vorgehen und auf rang
eins der eröffnung stehen kitas schulen
das ist doch politisch völlig unstrittig
aber danach wird es natürlich nicht ganz
einfach
ich würde mal sagen aus praktischen
gründen müssten wir dann bald die
friseure annehmen und aber das ist jetzt
mehr anekdotisch aber es gibt natürlich
dann um den einzelhandel und dann muss
man das immer weiter diskutieren und man
muss vor allen dingen immer gucken was
hat das für eine auswirkung sonst würden
wir uns glaube ich gleich wieder
zurückwerfen und darüber muss gesprochen
werden
und deshalb ist das auch richtig wir
werden jetzt staatlicherseits also wir
haben beim impfen jede folgendes problem
noch und solange kann man über
privilegien überhaupt nicht reden wir
wissen nicht ob der geimpfte nicht
trotzdem anderer anstecken kann und
diese frage ist noch nicht geklärt und
solange nicht geklärt ist stellt sich
diese frage der privilegien überhaupt
noch nicht aber politisch gesehen würde
ich sagen als start ist für uns schon
der punkt an dem wir jede mine
impfangebot machen können ein wichtiger
punkt wenn dann jemand sagt ich möchte
nicht geimpft werden okay wenn dann
jemand sagt okay dann ist das und das
nicht möglich das haben wir heute auch
schon wenn sie zum beispiel bestimmte
afrikanische länder reisen müssen sie
gegen bestimmte krankheiten geimpft sein
sonst kommen sie da gar nicht rein das
wird dann sicherlich eine internationale
diskussion seien aber wichtig ist dass
wir im augenblick nicht doppelte
privilegien wollen
ich habe das privileg schon geimpft zu
sein und dann habe
noch mehr privilegien obwohl ganz viele
menschen auch gerne genutzt werden
würden aber ist der hauptgrund ist jetzt
auch noch mal dass wir nicht wissen ob
die menschen weiter ansteckend sind
sodann ja wir brauchen ein gedenken an
die toten und der bundespräsident hat
dazu ja auch das gesagt was ihm wichtig
ist und ich gehe mal davon aus dass das
auch in die tat umgesetzt wird und dann
im jahr für junge erwachsene ist es die
schwierigste zeit man hat grossen
bewegungsräume will die welt
kennenlernen man will raus nehmen will
was erleben man muss lernen man muss
sich auf den beruf vorbereiten
wir haben versucht durch die
unterstützung für studierende durch
kurzarbeitergeld die hat das ja auch für
junge erwachsene gilt zu helfen und wir
bessern ja auch bei verschiedenen
programmen immer wieder nach das sehen
sie ja auch gerade im bereich der solo
selbstständigen damit beim einzelhandel
noch einmal nachgeschärft aber die
sozusagen die einschränkungen die junge
erwachsene sehen müssen die können wir
nicht voll kompensieren aber ich habe ja
auch in meinen gesprächen mit studenten
gesprochen
das wegfallen der ganzen 450 euro jobs
und das ist schon eine schwere sache und
deshalb haben wir ja hier auch versucht
zu helfen und werden das auch weiter tun
gut dann nehme noch fragen aus dem saal
kommen dann auch mal fragen von außen
zurück und machen jetzt weiter mit der
kollegin rechts reitschuster frau wolff
und dann kommt die nächste umsetzt
[Musik]
ja natürlich fordere ich die sofortige
freilassung von herrn navalny und das
tut die ganze bundesregierung wir
glauben dass das absolut richtig wäre
und auch sehr dringlich ist der die
andere frage
das grants also heute werden wir zum
aller ersten mal mit den europäischen
staats und regierungschefs über die
mutation sprechen und wir wären ja
sicherlich das gemeinsame ziel haben
dieses virus möglichst einzudämmen
das heißt es wird besondere vorkehrungen
da sind kombi alle einig bezüglich der
einreise aus großbritannien und zum
beispiel auch südafrika geben müssen
das hat deutschland ja auch bereits
veranlasst und es geht dann darum wie
wie können wir sicherstellen dass wir
alle miteinander das gleiche ziel
verfolgen nämlich die incidents
möglichst runterzubringen die sieben
tage instituts und wenn ich mir jetzt
heute mal die nachbarschaft von
deutschland anschaue dann habe ich da
auch gar nicht so sehr viel bedenken der
nieder nicht kollege von ihnen hat schon
nach den mechanischen maßnahmen gefragt
'wie verstärkt wurden
belgien ist sehr aufmerksam in
frankreich haben wir ähnliche
vorkehrungen wir haben
luxemburg die inzidenz die ist der
deutschen sehr vergleichbar
wir werden sicherlich mit der schweiz
reden müssen
wir werden mit tschechien bin ich schon
im gespräch habe schon zweimal mit dem
tschechischen ministerpräsidenten
gesprochen und es geht nicht darum
flächendeckende grenzkontrollen
einzuführen sondern wir werden versuchen
das zu verhindern vermeiden aber ich
sage ihnen ganz offen wenn ein land mit
einer vielleicht doppelte hohen instanz
für deutschland alle geschäfte auf macht
und wir haben sie noch zu
dann hat man natürlich ein problem und
deshalb wird heute ein eher eine erste
runde sein das muss aber nicht
abschliessend sein da wie wir da
miteinander verfahren ich glaube dass es
da sehr viel einverständnis gibt die
tücke liegt dann im detail und richtig
ist auch dass wir für die pendler test
regime entwickeln
da sind wir auch mit den nachbarländern
im gespräch das soll nicht heute die
politik von einem tag auf den anderen
gehen so dass keiner mehr aus dem
anderen land bei uns arbeiten kann da
haben wir ja alle dazugelernt
der freie warenverkehr ist sowieso
unstrittig aber wenn sie sich mal die in
die karte in deutschland anschauen dann
sieht man schon dass auch
infektionsgeschehen mit grenzen zu tun
hat das wäre er auch ganz ungewöhnlich
wenn das nicht der fall wäre so dass ich
heute keine abschließenden ergebnisse
erwarte aber dass ich glaube dass es
viel gemeinsamkeit gibt und dann werden
die innenminister auch noch einmal reden
müssen die gesundheitsminister wie man
das alles dann auch praktisch regelt wir
machen ja im europäischen rat keine
verordnung eine reise verordnung oder
ähnliches aber wir ich glaube ich kann
darstellen dass deutschland einen
kooperativen ansatz sucht und das für
uns auch die grenzkontrollen
flächendeckend die ultima ratio wären
und dass wir viel tun werden um zu
versuchen das zu verhindern
aber sie kann auch nicht vollkommen
ausgeschlossen werden wenn jemand ganz
andere vorstellungen hat dann kann es
auch nicht ausgeschlossen
reitschuster beim frau wolf dann freut
uns
wir haben das sind immer mehr den
vordergrund rücken
was erwartet uns hinten nähern
das kann im moment nicht genügend regen
wurde von störungen der funktionsbereich
zurück wurde in schächten vorgekommen
dass ein zeichnet beratungen der
vertreter von 0
es war kein einziger echter dabei
zwischen stadt und belegt derzeit nicht
freiwillig die bundesregierung denn ich
konnte nicht richtig
offensive ausmachen wir diese
touristische bericht sich die
geistlichen karten alle irgendwie auch
immer eine und nicht woher kommt er
nahrungsmittel sprecherin ausdrückte
gesagt dass sie sich zurückziehen wollen
natürlich in eine frage war die regel
entschuldigung wir haben gesagt eine wir
haben gesagt eine anfrage
die atmosphäre sie sagen ne kurze frage
dann stellen sie eine kurze frage nach
also ich finde wenn sie so gut meine
silvesteransprache zugehört haben haben
sie sicherlich alles gehört und als
erstes habe ich ja gesagt dass ich nicht
wieder antrete punkt ja und dann also
weder als bundestagsabgeordnete noch für
das amt der bundeskanzlerin
und dann habe ich gesagt voraussichtlich
im blick auf die letzte
regierungsbildung ich wünsche mir aber
dass die nächste regierung regierungs
bildungs super schnell verstanden gibt
aber das hatte ich mir 2017 schon
gewünscht
und dann hat sie bis hat etwas länger
gedauert und deshalb kam das
voraussichtlich sein aber der kernsatz
ich trete nicht wieder an und zwar für
keine politische funktion sodann die
wissenschaftler also wissen
das überrascht mich ein bisschen erstens
haben wir wählen wir die wissenschaftler
immer aus nach der frage was steht im
zentrum der beratungen diesmal stand die
mutationen im zentrum
und da hatten wir sehr interessante
wissenschaftler den herrenalb weiter der
für großbritannien die sequenzierung
durchgeführt hat dann haben wir den
professor nagel hier von einer
technischen universität berlin gehabt
der genauso wie herr meyer hermann
[Musik]
modellierung macht wir hatten ja ein
professor krause der vom helmholtz
institut in braunschweig der dezidiert
in vielen fragen anderer meinung ist
und schauen sie es gibt ein breites
spektrum an wissenschaftlern und nicht
nur die die jetzt gerade eingeladen sind
sind diejenigen mit denen ich spreche
mit den mit deren ergebnisse ich mich
befasse aber es gibt in dem ganzen auch
politische grundentscheidung wir haben
mit wissenschaft nichts zu tun jeder
arbeitet jeder wissenschaftler arbeitet
nach besten wissen und gewissen
aber die grundentscheidung heißt die
will ich darauf setzen
doch natürlich durch den impfstoff etwas
weniger ausgeprägt darauf setzen immer
sich so viel wie möglich leute anstecken
zu lassen um dann doch irgendwo zu einer
besseren durchseuchung vielleicht der
jüngeren hört sich schrecklich an das
wort also zu einer besseren infektions
immunität sage ich mal jüngere
altersgruppen zu kommen oder will ich
das nicht
und diese politische entscheidung die
habe ich getroffen da kann ich trotzdem
die wissenschaftlichen studien lesen
aber die bei uns nimmt ja keiner die
entscheidung ab und diese politische
entscheidung habe ich getroffen weil ich
weiß professor krömer hat mir gesagt auf
der charité vor kurzer zeit war das
durchschnittsalter der dort liegenden
menschen 63
und da wir wissen dass die todesrate
natürlich bei den älteren viel viel
höher ist oder die schwere der schwere
verlauf wissen sie wenn 63 der
durchschnitt ist wie viele jüngere auch
davon betroffen sind
und ich finde das kann man dieses risiko
kann man nicht eingehen ich möchte es
nicht eingehen aber daraus leiten sich
dann natürlich politische handlungen ab
und trotzdem verfolge ich natürlich alle
meinungsbildung und wir haben ja wir
sind ja nicht jemand der irgendwie
ignorant ist aber uns mit der einladung
von bestimmten wissenschaftlern wollen
wir auf bestimmte fragen die uns
interessieren und die nicht politischer
natur sind antworten bekommen aber
dahinter liegen natürlich auch
politische grundentscheidung und die
sozusagen gruppe die er zur
herdenimmunität neigt da gibt es viele
viele nerven
diese grundentscheidung presse ich an
frau wolf hat uns herr remmel hinter der
maske sieht man noch schlechter wäre ja
es gibt ja es gibt ja worte da wird
reflexartig darauf reagiert und es sind
ja auch sehr schlechte erinnerungen
verbunden mit der grenzschließung die im
übrigen nicht von deutschland aus gegen
damals in richtung polen zum beispiel
den langen kilometerlangen staus das
wird es sowieso nicht wieder geben das
ist überhaupt der freie warenverkehr
steht jetzt eben ob überhaupt nicht zur
debatte sondern es ist über die frage
was passiert in den grenzregionen wo
sehr viele pendler sind da haben wir
jetzt mit unserer reise verordnung tests
strategien vorgegeben die kann man nicht
von einem tag auf den anderen einführen
da kann man aber auch nicht bis zum
sankt nimmerleinstag warten
und da wird deutschland auch seinen
beitrag dazu leisten dass die pendler
getestet werden können und man wird das
nicht nur von den herkunftsländern
erwarten
da sind wir wie gesagt im guten gespräch
ich als oder als bundeskanzlerin habe
ich aber auch die aufgabe zu gucken ich
verlange von den bürgerinnen und bürgern
der bundesrepublik deutschland eine
menge geschlossene schulen geschlossene
geschäfte geschlossenen restaurants
keine kunst veranstaltung dann ist es
doch natürlich dass ich jetzt nicht
offenen auges zu sehen kann das
vielleicht wenn anderswo ganz anders
gehandelt wird dass wir dann sagen naja
gut also jetzt können alle deutschen mal
nachbarland fahren und dort dort kaffee
trinken gehen die restaurants gehen und
mit einer viel höheren instanz das würde
die bürger mit recht nicht verstehen und
gleich fertig heißt dass wir im
wesentlichen das gleiche ziel haben
dafür gibt es die cd cd arbeit mehr
zusammen in der europäischen
gesundheitsbehörde und ich weiß das von
frankreich bis niederlande bis vielen
unserer nachbarländer die vorstellungen
so mit 50.000 in sieben tagen also diese
incidents werte auch dass deren
grundsätzliches ziel sind das ist nicht
einfach das zu erreichen
aber frankreich wollte damals auch 5000
fälle pro sieben tage und darauf
arbeiten alle hin
und ob jetzt die ausgangs beschränkung
das maß der dinge ist ob einer die
schule mehr auf fest oder weniger ob die
notbetreuung 20 oder 30 prozent sind
darüber wird man nicht richten
man wird sich die kurven angucken und
wird sagen dass einem exponentiellen
wachstum und hat trotzdem noch alle
restaurants auf dann muss man sagen gibt
es vielleicht grenzkontrollen wenn aber
was ich aber gar nicht so sehr weil ich
ja um uns herum sehe dass da auch
härteste beschränkungen eingeführt
werden so das ist der maßstab also ich
bin ganz entschieden dafür dass wir da
sehr gut miteinander kooperieren dass
wir darüber sprechen und dass wir jetzt
nicht sozusagen immer vom schlechtesten
fall ausgehen
aber ich bin verpflichtet den hier
lebenden menschen zu sagen wir können
uns nicht alle eure einschränkungen
dadurch zunichte machen lassen das
woanders vielleicht etwas ganz anderes
bild von uns jetzt
[Musik]
eine ganz neue kombination von regieren
durchregieren hat man ja schon ihr wort
würde ich mir nicht zu eigen machen nein
erstens ist da ziemlich wenig zeit
zweitens wissen sie gar nicht was morgen
passiert wir können noch mit ganz
anderen problemen konfrontiert werden
dass ich glaube jeder regierung stars
gleich ernst genommen werden und immer
wieder mit den gleichen wachen blick was
für probleme deuten sich an also man
kann sich da nicht damit aufhalten ob
das jetzt der letzte 20 januar war oder
21 jahre und deshalb ist das nichts was
mich so bewegt also die betrachtung habe
ich nicht sie schauen sie sie schreiben
ja über mich oder über das was ich sage
und 2
da haben sie eine andere perspektive
aber meine perspektive ist mitten im
leben und möglichst vernünftig regieren
und zwar bis zum letzten tag in dem ich
die verantwortung habe
ja das gefühl es an gespannte
aufmerksamkeit und dies unterscheidet
sich nicht von dem fünften tag meiner
amtsführung herr remmel selbst und dann
kommen wir mal zu fragen zur außen zum
abschluss naja da müssen wir schon
ja wir sind gehen auf das ende zu ist
das mikrofon
[Musik]
ich meine grundsätzliche einstellung zu
system 2 hat sich nicht verändert für
mich war wichtig dass die ukraine einen
gasvertrag bekommt und wir werden
natürlich mit der neuen amerikanischen
administration weil das ja sehr
parteiübergreifend in den reichen
staaten von amerika kritisch gesehen
wird und ja auch in teilen europas
kritisch gesehen wird darüber sprechen
da müssen aber auch darüber sprechen
welche welche wirtschaftsbeziehungen im
gasbereich mit russland akzeptabel sind
und welche nicht
und es ist auch nicht so dass der auch
dass zwischen den vereinigten staaten
von amerika und russland gar keine
handelsbeziehungen im ölbereich bestehen
zum beispiel das müssen wir dann alles
auf den tisch legen und mal bei uns
unterhalten ob man gar kein handel mit
russland mehr im gasbereich haben will
welche abhängigkeit tolerabel ist und
desweiteren finde ich diese
exterritorialen sanktionen sowieso ein
mittel was aus meiner sicht nicht in
ordnung ist und es wird auch mit der
beiden administration unterschiedliche
meinungen geben es gab zum beispiel ich
glaube das hat es früher auch eine rolle
gespielt ich war zum beispiel immer
gegen bestimmte formen von
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine da war
die freistaaten und da barack obama und
mit auch gerade die beiden auch
unterschiedlicher meinung also glauben
sie nicht dass das jetzt immer von
morgens an nur übereinstimmung gibt da
wird es auch unterschiedliche meinungen
geben
position hat sich nicht in eine
erinnerung an ihre letzte potenzierung
ist die nach das hab ich habe gesagt
dass das auch eine rolle spielen kann
ich sage heute dass die sanktionen ja
sowieso noch mal wieder verstärkt werden
aber dass ich meine grundeinstellung
noch nicht dahingehend verändert hat
dass ich sage das projekt sollte es
nicht geben
dann haben wir zum abschluss nochmal
eine runde fragen von außen vorgelesen
von mathis feldhoff
das gibt es in der gemeinde herrschen
verschiedenen stoffen strom ins
öffentliche netz abgespielt hat und wir
möchten also gefragt nach ihren
gesundheitlichen september würden die
kinder besser ausgestattet werden muss
sagen dass trotz bemühungen dass er in
erstens zu der korona waren app und dem
datenschutz ich glaube dass der
datenschutz sehr sehr wichtig ist und
dass er auch sehr viel zu tun hat mit
der akzeptanz einer corona waren alleine
corner warm up für sehr viel weniger
nutzer mit einem geringeren datenschutz
wäre auch nicht gut aber es wird dort
auch etwas immer wieder diskutiert was
wir zwar versucht haben schon sehr oft
zu erklären aber was sehr sehr schwierig
offensichtlich zu erklären ist
sie können zwei einsätze fahren sie
können den zentralen und den dezentralen
nehmen wir haben uns für den dezentralen
ansatz entschieden das heißt wenn sie in
der straßenbahn sitzen und neben ihnen
sitzen andere leute und es ist jemand
infiziert dann bekommt bekommen
der minivan der infizierte sozusagen den
knopf drückt dann bekommen alle die in
meiner umgebung waren eine information
würde man das jetzt nicht anonymisiert
machen
dann müsste man sozusagen würden alle
handynummern aller derjenigen die jemals
in meiner umgebung waren sichtbar werden
und dann vom gesundheitsamt angerufen
und dann würde man sagen so du warst
dann und damit dem unternehmen in der
straßenbahn und so weiter das würde
schon mal wie ich finde
ob es die gesundheitsämter soviel
entlasten würde weiß ich nicht weil der
informierte er die gleiche information
bekommt und zweitens würde es glaube ich
schon debatten hervorrufen und ich war
also ich denke dass die akzeptanz
geringer werden es gibt aber noch einen
zweiten grund den darf man nicht
unterschätzen wir müssen mit den
betriebssystem herstellern arbeiten und
in dem falle des ansatzes der central
wäre müsste eine müsste diese bluetooth
meldung ganz anders sozusagen angelegt
sein und man hätte dann das wird nicht
unterstützt weil auch die hersteller der
betriebssysteme eine gewisse stolz sind
auf die auf den datenschutz in ihren
handys und wenn man nur für diese waren
etwas anders machen müsste müsste man
das jedes mal aus allen anderen
anwendungen rausnehmen in den
vordergrund holen mit großen
stromverbrauch aber es wird einfach auch
nicht unterstützt von apple zum beispiel
und bei apple eine andere philosophie
hat
und deshalb ist es müßig jetzt sich mit
der frage immer wieder zu beschäftigen
und es gibt die möglichkeit der
freiwilligen daten spende
niemand ist daran gehindert im
gesundheitsamt seine daten zu geben da
kann man mehr tun und ich glaube das ist
der weg auf dem wir gehen sollten dann
ich gucke sie immer an als hätten sie
persönlich gefragt aber sie sind jetzt
sozusagen rechnen sodann ich habe in der
tat mit dem russischen präsidenten
gesprochen
das wird immer wieder gesagt russland
hat diesen impfstoff splitting v und ich
habe gesagt wenn wir da gemeinsam
arbeiten wollen ich finde über alle
politischen differenzen die ihr im
augenblick groß sind hinweg kann man
einer pandemie auf dem humanitären
bereich zusammenarbeiten was dafür die
voraussetzung ist dass das ein impfstoff
der in der europäischen union eingesetzt
wird und den wir auch gemeinsam
produzieren können die zulassung durch
die europäische medizin agentur ist und
russland hat sich jetzt an die eu
gewandt und wir ich habe angeboten dass
unser paul-ehrlich-institut war es ja
unser institut ist russland dabei
unterstützen kann weil man ja vielleicht
mit diesem weg den die eu fordert und
den dokumenten nicht voll übereinstimmt
und das finde ich ist
eine gute sache und wenn dieser
impfstoff zugelassen wird von der ema
dann können wir auch über gemeinsame
produktion reden oder auch über
anwendung und drittens es gibt ungefähr
380 gesundheitsämter für die ich mich
sehr interessieren für die wir geld
bereitgestellt haben damit neue leute
eingestellt werden können ich kann die
menschen nicht alle persönlich
einstellen es ist nicht richtig dass
nirgends jemand eingestellt wurde aber
es ist sicherlich richtig dass nicht
überall jemand eingestellt wurde
wir haben eigentlich gesagt mit dem
ministerpräsidenten das bis anfang
januar ein gemeinsames kontakt nach
verfolgungs system installiert werden
soll nämlich sommers das ist leider bis
anfang januar nicht gelungen weil einige
länder und die gesundheitsämter arbeiten
jetzt ja auch unter hochdruck gesagt
haben wir haben andere gleichwertige
systeme wir wollen schnittstellen zu dem
anderen zu dem rk ii und jetzt sagen wir
stellen auf sommers um wir haben jetzt
festgelegt dass ende februar wird jeder
sommers installiert haben aber den
gebrauch von sommers können wir mitten
in der grössten anspannung die die
gesundheitsämter erleben jetzt nicht
umstellen von mikado in rheinland pfalz
auf sommers in dem gewünschten format
sehr kurzfristig allerdings plädiere ich
dafür dass alle sich für ein system
entscheiden weil ansonsten die
weiterentwicklung des systems natürlich
nie harmonisch sein wird weiß ich mikado
wahrscheinlich nicht so weiterentwickelt
wie sommers und weil die schnittstelle
dabei eröffnet usw
zudem ist dann immer wieder neu gemacht
werden muss das heißt ein
bundeseinheitlicher ansatz wäre hier
schon gut die grund sache die grundlage
dafür ist da ich bleibe weiterhin mit
den gesundheitsämtern gespräch denn wir
brauchen noch mal eine verstärkte
kontakt nachverfolgung alle die ein
digitales system installiert haben
insbesondere sommers können sehr viel
einfacher dann auch in von call centern
aus die kontakt nach verfolgung in
anspruch nehmen und wir wollen gerade in
den semesterferien auch studenten dazu
anreizen das könnte dann ein guter
nebenjob sein den man sonst nicht hat
sie kontakt nachverfolgung mit zu
unterstützen wenn wir dann
zu einer öffnung strategie kommt also
ich habe mich in den letzten monaten
sehr viel mit mit großem respekt für
gesundheitsämter interessiert weil
gesundheitsämter nehmen manche andere
gruppe aber auch großes leisten es wird
noch viele fragen geben im saal das weiß
ich auch von außen sind längst nicht
alle fragen gestellt ich bitte um
verständnis ich bitte um nachsicht dass
wir jetzt aus den genannten gründen in
unser aller schutzinteresse den zeit
haben so gezogen haben wir ist
vielleicht die bundeskanzlerin im wissen
dass ich nicht anfragen bekommen sie
nochmals vielen dank morgen um 10 gibt's
die nächste pressekonferenz zum thema
mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister um
chef des robert koch instituts in
virologen posten um den präsidenten der
gesellschaft für intensiv und
notfallmedizin markt um 10 uhr hier an
dieser stelle
frau bundeskanzlerin ärgert vielen dank
für ihren besuch dankeschön
soweit also die pressekonferenz mit
bundeskanzlerin merkel
das hat jetzt gut eine stunde 15 minuten
gedauert jetzt sich ein bisschen mehr
zeit und nochmals wir gedacht haben hat
zu vielen themenfeldern gesprochen und
wir wollen das jetzt noch mal
zusammenfassend für alle die ja
vielleicht nicht alles mitbekommen haben
von anfang an das war zwar ein bisschen
gedauert mit meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann
die hat fleißig zugehört und sich
hoffentlich ganz viel gemerkt nicole
fast nochmals zusammen welche
themenfelder haben wir denn er zu
gestrich gestriffen ist das was ich
gesucht habe sei nicht gestrichen
ich habe mir nicht nur ganz viel gemerkt
ich habe mir vorsichtshalber auch ein
bisschen was aufgeschrieben also
natürlich nicht überraschend war das
beherrschende thema corona mit den mit
den unterschiedlichen verästelungen was
dann die unternehmen angeht also über
die richtig ist es die schule weiter
geschlossen zu halten wie falsch ist es
die schulen weiter geschlossen zu halten
warum hat man die maßnahmen vorgestern
so
beschlossen wie man sie beschlossen hat
wie ist das verhältnis zu den
ministerpräsidentinnen da gibt es ja
immer wieder konflikte eben bei den
gemeinsamen treffen
wie läuft es mit dem impfen warum läuft
es mit dem impfen so wie es läuft und so
weiter ein thema das auch mehrere male
gefragt wurde von anderen
journalistinnen war die der amtsantritt
das verhältnis von angela merkel zum
gestern ja vereidigten neuen us
präsidenten joe biden dabei nie war auch
eine ein thema das verhältnis zu
russland nachdem der krimi kritiker ja
nach seiner rückkehr nach seiner
mutmaßlichen vergiftung durch russland
nach russland von deutschland aus jetzt
zurückgeflogen war vor ein paar tagen
nach russland dort direkt am flughafen
festgenommen worden war
ich glaube das waren so die themen und
natürlich auch so ist wurde auch etwas
persönlicher es ist ja angela merkels
letzte amtszeit wir wissen im september
wird gewählt da gab es dann so 23
persönliche fragen dazu ob sie wirklich
nicht noch mal antritt nein sie tritt
nicht noch mal an sagt sie heute auch
noch mal und ob sie gelöst da im moment
politik macht weil sie weiß es ist
demnächst vorbei und hat sie gesagt nein
man muss jeden tag so ernst nehmen wie
den anderen
ich glaube aber die meisten
interessieren sich hier bei uns im
stream für die ganzen corona statements
diese gegeben hat ihr könnt auch gerne
fragen stellen also und wenn er was
nicht mitbekommen habt wenn ihr das
nicht verstanden hat versuchen wir das
hier einzusortieren
fangen wir mal vielleicht am mit einer
großen frage nach den impfstoffen da
gibt es ja viel kritik ist es hakt es
kommt nicht genug an
teilweise können die impfzentren
überhaupt nicht so arbeiten wie sie
eigentlich arbeiten wollten was hat sie
denn da gesagt das war die stelle in der
pressekonferenz heute bei der ich
generell den eindruck hatte dass sie
sehr aufgeräumt war auch ein bisschen
ausgeschlafener wird es vorgestern abend
nach stundenlangen verhandlungen mit dem
ministerpräsidentin
da dachte ich okay ja genau also sie war
generell heute finde ich entspannt und
auch bereit viel zu erklären das hat sie
auch relativ früh gesagt in ihrer
pressekonferenz dass sie glaubt dass es
ein großes bedürfnis gibt in diesem land
zu wissen was sie und die anderen
politischen länder leitet aber an einer
stelle und eben da ging es auch um das
thema impfen da hatte ich den eindruck
da blickte man so ein bisschen mehr in
sie hinein und merkte sie findet die
berichterstattung der zum teil
anscheinend auch unfair auch die kritik
unter anderem vom koalitionspartner spd
da sagt sie diese wortwörtlich hat sie
von äckern gesprochen
das findet sie nicht gerechtfertigt sie
hat noch mal skizziert wie es ihrer
ansicht nach aussieht was für eine große
leistung es ist so schnell überhaupt
einen impfstoff entwickelt zu haben und
auch die zulassung bekommen zu haben und
auch schon in die produktion zu gehen
also die kritik hat sie sich nicht
gefallen lassen und auch von ihrem
gesundheitsministerien sparen der wie
sie in der cdu ist aber nochmal zu
nehmen versucht hier kommen wieder viele
fragen zu dem thema studierende und
universitäten hat sie da irgendwas jetzt
mal konkret zugesagt nein
konkret wurde sie dazu aber auch nicht
gefragt das muss man dazu sagen das
haben wir ja auch vorgestern abend und
ich als wir in derselben konstellation
über die ministerpräsidentin der
konferenz gesprochen haben festgestellt
dass das thema komplett untergeht also
sie hat verständnis dafür geäußert dass
es auch für studierende für junge leute
eine sehr sehr schwierige phase ist aber
ansonsten wurde darüber heute überhaupt
nicht gesprochen da hier ist kommen also
wirklich die fragen sind auch so was wie
wieso warum sind private unis weiterhin
offen
440 beschwert dass auch die uni
professoren selber überhaupt nicht sagen
können was als nächstes passiert also da
wirklich große verunsicherung beim thema
kostenlose masken das ist ja auch ein
streitthema gewesen damit wo gab es viel
kritik
dass gesagt wird okay erfährt mit zwei
masten schützen aber die sind halt auch
echt teuer
was hat sie dazu gesagt
ja darauf danach ist sie tatsächlich
gefragt worden dass sie noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass ist es geht ja um die
pflicht die jetzt kommen soll
ffp zwei masten oder eben andere masken
im öffentlichen personennahverkehr zu
tragen und beim einkaufen hat sie noch
einmal gesagt es geht auch aus dieser
überlegung heraus
es geht nicht nur um ffp zwei masten
sind auch diese sogenannten op masken
erlaubt die sagt merkel ja auch
günstiger seien als die ffb zwei masten
und konkret zum thema kostenlose massen
zum beispiel für hartz4 empfänger innen
für studentinnen da sagt sie wir schauen
jetzt mal wie lange wie diese regelung
aufrechterhalten und sollte das länger
laufen dann wird das durchaus ein thema
werden was im umkehrschluss aber heißt
im moment ist das noch kein thema
und im moment wenn man kein geld hat
muss man sich halt eine günstigere maske
sorgen die vielleicht dann auch nicht so
gut schützt nur das ist schon ein
bisschen fragwürdig dass sich die
bundesregierung da so raus hält oder ja
das ist problematisch das hat man an
ihrer antwort darauf ja indirekt ist hab
ich gerade schon gesagt auch gehört also
zu sagen wir gucken jetzt mal wie lange
diese pflicht besteht heißt ja nicht wir
haben da jetzt konkret was war das ist
aber auch so eine beliebte merkel
strategien immer zu sagen wir gucken
jetzt mal was dann passiert eine sache
gibt es ja diese logik strategie die
wird von führenden wissenschaftler innen
empfohlen ich wie können wir ganz kurz
zeigen ich habe einen artikel hier
aufgemacht ist tatsächlich heute im
wissenschaftsjournal so lancet
erschienen den action plan für pan
european defence against news koch to
various also wo es wirklich um die
rotation geht und es wird eine
gemeinsame anstrengung gefordert ich
packe euch den link auch gerne mal ich
jetzt in den youtube stream ich hier
offen habe wenn ihr das lesen wollte ist
ein sehr langes ding was was hat sie
dazu gesagt also tatsächlich so sondern
no go it strategie und auch zu der
europäischen zusammenarbeit die ja doch
manchmal besser und manchmal schlechter
läuft
also zur nakowitz strategie hatte sich
sehr differenziert geäußert und aber
auch sehr klar sie hat das noch mal
skizziert wie diese logik strategie
aussieht ich kann da mal werbung machen
für die kolleginnen von zeit online die
haben das dann wissenschaftsredakteur
das sehr sehr sehr detailliert und sehr
gut nachvollziehbar für
naturwissenschaft idioten wie mich zum
beispiel aufgedröselt selbst ich habe es
verstanden da hat sie heute gesagt also
hat es nicht bewertet das man als erstes
sondern sie hat es noch mal erklärt und
hat an einer stelle aber gesagt wir sind
nicht nur für epidemiologie zuständig
das ist die spannung wir sind für
politik zuständig das heißt sie sagt
implizit heißt das es gibt gute
argumente für die solo kowitz strategie
aber ab einem gewissen punkt so hat sie
das auch ausgeführt sind die zahlen die
blanken zahlen sprechen dafür
trotzdem weiter harte riffs
restriktionen beizubehalten weil man
eben noch niedriger will mit den zahlen
wir als politisch handelnde müssen dann
aber überlegen ob wir diese harten
restriktionen trotzdem beibehalten
können das heißt man muss es den leuten
auch verkaufen können
man muss es den leuten erklären können
und man muss es den leuten so gut
erklären können und so nachvollziehbar
dass sie sich dann darauf daran auch
halten also sagen wir mal wir haben eine
instanz zahl von zehn ja dann kann ich
mir vorstellen dass auch leute die
bisher immer noch und das ist ja noch
die große mehrheit einverstanden sind
mit den mit den maßnahmen dass die dann
sagen entschuldigung inzidenz von zehn
wir lagen mal bei uns im landkreis bei
500 warum soll ich denn jetzt nicht
shoppen gehen können warum machen die
läden denn ich wieder auf wenn wir zum
beispiel trotzdem eine maske tragen also
nochmal das sagt angela merkel zur kur
wird das ist eben dieser spannung diese
dieses spannungsfeld in dem sie sich als
politikerin bewegt zum europäischen zur
gemeinsamen europäischen zum gemeinsamen
europäische vorgehen jetzt habe ich sagt
sie es läuft eigentlich ganz gut das
letzte
was sie will sind grenzschließungen
heute abend gibt es ja einen digitalen
europäischen gipfel aller eu regierungs
und staatschefs und chefinnen da sagt
sie also sie will es auf jeden fall
verhindern dass grenzen geschlossen
werden
sie sieht auch in vor allem in den
deutschen nachbarländern dass man da zu
ähnlichen maßnahmen greift wie wie hier
in deutschland um die instanzen zu
senken
sie sagt aber aber vielleicht kann man
grenzschließung nicht verhindern wenn
wir sehen in einem nachbarland zum
beispiel lockert mann obwohl die zahlen
dort immer noch sehr hoch sind öffnung
zum beispiel die restaurants und dann
überlegen sich die deutschen die zum
beispiel grenzen ihr wohnen ich fahre
mal rüber und jeder essen und dann sagt
sie das kann ich dann wiederum dem rest
der bevölkerung nicht erklären ja also
sie ist da optimistisch aber hat auch
eine klare haltung will aber eben alles
ausschließen also eine lange pk mit
einigen aussagen manchmal etwas vagen
erklärungen das kann sie ja ganz gut und
darüber spreche ich jetzt gerne mit dem
sozialpsychologen florian kurz nach
vielen dank nicole dass du hier da für
uns da was alles beobachtet und bewertet
hast ich denke wir sehen uns bald wieder
nach berlin
ganz kurze anmerkung hier weil es fragen
zu uns im chat gibt auch 4 kommentare
löschen natürlich flächen kommentare wir
löschen alles was ursache nicht
beleidigend und einfach nicht faktisch
richtig ist deswegen passiert aber nicht
ohne grund und über diese ganze
kommunikationsstrategie der
bundesregierung und auch der
ministerpräsidentinnen möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit dem heidelberger
sozialpsychologen florian kurz nachher
kurz nach sie haben die tk ist ja auch
vielleicht in teilen verfolgt wie würden
sie jetzt aus ihrer sichtweise diesen
auftritt bewerten
ich bin eine ganz gute note geben heute
der frau merkel mit nicht arrogant sein
aber ich finde den vergleich zur pk nach
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
dienstag die aufschlussreich wie haben
sie wie haben sie das damals gemacht
also wo sie ist ein unterschied ich
meine klar sie müde am dienstag es hat
lange gedauert heute morgen war sie
ausgeschlafen
das war der unterschied und noch genau
die
also etwas genereller ich glaube wenn
wir von den menschen brauchen das wir
dass sie weiterhin mit den ganzen kroner
maßen und das maßnahmen dass das wesen
dann müssen sie vertrauen haben wenn das
was die politiker verordnen und machen
und für vertrauensvolle kommunikation
gibt einfach drei prinzipien und je
eines der wichtigsten ist ich muss wohl
wollen signalisieren ich muss zum
beispiel klar machen ich habe verstanden
was die bedürfnisse verschiedener
parteien sind und verschiedene
interessensgruppen und an dieser hat
sich noch so etwas gesagt wie wir
verlangen den bürgern viel ab und wir
handeln nach dem vorsorgeprinzip und
gibt ihnen rechtlich vor beim home
office lösungen das ist zu abstrakt zu
wenig differenziert da hat sie proaktiv
nicht gezeigt die hat sich wirklich
damit auseinandergesetzt
wahrscheinlich hat sie das heute auf
nach berger sieht das sehr gut gemacht
dass sie alle wesentlichen
interessensgruppen durchgegangen sollen
den eltern bis zu den
restaurantbesitzern bis zu den firmen
die ihre produktion am laufen halten
müssen
warum ist ein statement ich weiß dass er
den bürgern viel abverlangen in ihren
augen als nicht so richtig förderlich
also man könnte auch sagen so schön dass
sie uns sieht und dass ich weiß dass das
viel verlangt ist weil das nicht konkret
genug ist also einer der eine der
wesentlichen ratschläge wenn man
vertrauen erzeugen möchte ist zu zeigen
dass man sich ganz konkret
auseinandergesetzt hatten den dingen
also da kann man zum beispiel auch mal
den herrn söder vom dienstag zitieren
der dann konkret geworden ist bei den
anliegen hinsichtlich bildungsqualität
und schule der da gesagt hat naja wir
müssen halt über die anzahl der
prüfungen reden fürs weiterkommen und so
was also da zeigt man sich konkret dass
man dann selbst hat aber interessant
dass er jetzt händler ansprechen das ist
ja doch auch problem teilweise dass die
ministerpräsidentinnen und die
bundeskanzlerin sich erst äußern
gemeinsam nach langen gesprächen und
hinterher doch wieder auseinander rennen
da hat frau merkel auch gerade quasi
gesagt ja das ist anstrengend manchmal
aber das gehört halt dazu
ist aber doch etwas was in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung bitter
beschäftigen sie sich ja doch ziemlich
schwierig ist da hätte ich nicht da bin
ich mir nicht sicher ob das nicht ein
etwas überbetont problem ist also auch
noch mal die am dienstag das betonen
dass es schwierige verhandlungen waren
und das besonders zu den schulen und
kitas sehr viel diskutiert wurde
ich glaube das ist gut und vertrauen zu
schaffen ja es ist muss unterschiedliche
meinungen geben und das weiß jeder und
so zu tun als wäre alles einhellig das
schafft nicht vertrauen
beim zweiten punkt man muss
signalisieren dass man in t gehandelt
und da gehörte deckel dissens und
kontroversen offenzulegen gehört er dazu
aber wenn wenn wir jetzt am dienstag
passiert ist frau merkel herr müller aus
berlin der bürgermeister und bayerns
ministerpräsident wieder auf dem podium
sitzen etwas bekannt geben was eben auch
schwierig war mit den schulen und
parallel quast quasi dazu in baden
württemberg der ministerpräsident herr
kretschmer vor die vor die man vor die
presse tritt und sagt ja also wenn wir
können machen wir schon früher auf dann
ist das doch in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung ja doch ein bisschen
interessant oder ja unter umständen und
es wurde ja auch schon diskutiert wie
sehr kann
die bundesregierung habe noch gewisse
maßnahmen durchsetzen
da geht es ja dann geht es um einen
weiteren aspekt der der vertrauensvolle
kommunikation nämlich kompetenz also
kann ich zeigen dass ich in der lage bin
dinge umzusetzen fehler zu erkennen und
zu korrigieren wenn wir noch mal auf die
finger vom dienstag nun von heute kommen
da finde ich haben alle inklusive
vermerk sehr gut abgeschnitten also ich
meine ihre große stärke die
internationale europäische kommunikation
und kooperation das ist wiederholt und
sehr oft und sehr glaubhaft betont sie
hat ganz mit mit detailwissen geglänzt
heute hinsichtlich der gesundheitsämter
und der system die dahinter stecken ich
glaube das war sehr wichtig und sieht
auch diese die sie im raum stehende
frage warum jetzt auf einmal der kp2
masken bisher wurde uns doch gesagt das
machst dann seien gut genug
auch das wurde am dienstag relativ klar
gesagt na ja wir haben eine aggressive
das größte brauchen besser masken ja
also da kompetenz mäßig glaube ich habe
sie ganz gut abgeschnitten
das ist ja aber an der sache die auch
immer wieder auffällt bei frau merkel
die doch mit viel detailwissen häufig
glänzt die wenn man sie länger reden
lässt oder den länger zuhören kann doch
auch wirklich sehr komplexe sachverhalte
schildern kann
auf der anderen seite stehen dann
politiker die eher markige sprüche
machen was kommt denn in der
kommunikation besser an
ich glaube das muss man differenzieren
also im moment sind wir glaube ich in
der phase wo vertrauen gewinnen das
einzige dieser ist das motto der stunde
also ich bin ich brauche vertrauen in
das was ich tue sonst spielen die
menschen nicht mit und werden das
wichtigste buchen kann
um die epidemie zu verlangsamen und
kontakte zu reduzieren das wird nie
jemand irgendwie sinnvoll prüfen können
der operation angewiesen und da ist
differenziert seien die einzige lösung
nach markige sprüche brauche ich in den
akuten krisen lage am anfang auf euch
klare ansagen und dann muss ich immer
mehr erklären warum weshalb und wenig
dazu würde ich auch gerne noch einen
punkt los werden also ich meine ich
glaube ein anderes thema was immer
wichtiger wird jetzt im verlauf der
pandemie ist schon so ein bisschen die
politisierung der wissenschaft da bin
ich natürlich auch teilen davon als
wissenschaftler
aber das ist mir sehr aufgestoßen am
dienstag dass zb der herr müller gesagt
haben wir hatten acht experten die waren
sich alle einig da muss jeder
wissenschaftler denken mir dann habt ihr
die falschen experten ausgewählt weil es
kann nicht sein dass sich alle
wissenschaften irgendwie eigentlich
erstmal wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber
das so darzustellen dass untergräbt die
wahrnehmung dass hier integer
kommuniziert wird weil es ja das wissen
wir ja es gibt hier wissenschaftler
innen die das anders sehen die auch
sagen wir brauchen andere maßnahmen oder
wir brauchen weniger maßnahmen
das heißt dienen würden sie zumindest
mehr raum geben in der politischen
kommunikation
ich würde mehr raum geben der tatsache
wie ich welche wissenschaftlerinnen aus
würde
und heute ist das durchgekommen auf
nachfrage da hat sie mal habe bekannte
frau merkel warum welche wissenschaftler
ausgewählt und nicht ausgewählt werden
zumindest auf der kategorie
herdenimmunität ich weiß es nicht
da hat sie eine politische entscheidung
getroffen das ist gute gute guter praxis
gute praxis um
nt geld zu kommen jetzt hier natürlich
könnte man sagen da kann man noch viel
weiter gehen
also man kann ja man könnte ja auch die
inhalte der beratung die standpunkte der
einzelnen wissenschaftler transparent
machen das würde noch mehr integrität
schaffen wahrnehmung von integrität das
passiert bisher nicht das ist
der in beratung hinter geschlossener tür
jetzt gibt es ja eine frage von floskeln
auf facebook der fragt worin liegen die
gründe dass ausgerechnet die
impfbereitschaft des pflegepersonals
relativ gering ausgeprägt ist würden sie
das auch in einer falschen oder
mangelnde kommunikation sehen
bei den jetzt sind wir so bei den
konkreten verhaltensweisen und disziplin
bereitschaft da muss man erst mal
aufpassen dass man nicht einige wenige
beispiele zu einer mehrheitsmeinung
macht
ich habe die untersuchungen noch nicht
gesehen wo tatsächlich mal die
impfbereitschaft untersucht wurde die
kann es wahrscheinlich auch noch gar
nicht geben dass es immer einzelne gibt
nichts bereit sind sie impfen zu lassen
ist klar und es ist auch klar dass die
je näher und konkret dass eine impfung
wird desto mehr werden die negativen und
möglicherweise negativen aspekte bekannt
und treten in unseren in unserem in
unserem abwägungs bereich also das ist
nicht das ist nicht über das ist nicht
überraschend ich würde mal in frage
stellen ob das wirklich ein weit eine
groß angelegte ablehnung
es ist zumindest so groß dass darüber
öffentlich diskutiert wird das auch
schon darüber mal nachgedacht wurde ob
es eine impfpflicht für diese
berufsgruppen gibt ist dass das ist ja
dann auch wieder etwas was die
öffentliche wahrnehmung und das reden
miteinander beeinflusst
ja genau also ich kann noch was zur
impfpflicht impfpflicht sagen und auch
zu den weiteren verschärfungen und so
also das ist natürlich auch etwas das
dieses diese diese ganze kommunikation
noch vertrauensbasis die führt letztlich
dazu dass man das gefühl hat man wird
auf augenhöhe behandelt
und wenn man mit zuckerbrot und peitsche
zu nehmen gebracht wird wie zum beispiel
zum home office wie das gerade
vorgeschlagen wurde heute dann ist das
keine kommunikation auf augenhöhe das
ist eher eine von dem von den
vorgesetzten von der vorgesetzten und
untergebenen oder von einem elternteil
sein kind das wollen die arbeitgeber
nicht mitziehen und nicht tatsächlich
die möglichkeit geben ihren
arbeitnehmern auch von zu hause zu
arbeiten mit verweis auf präsenzpflicht
dann muss man doch irgendwann als
politik auch mal eingreifen oder nicht
ja das kann man machen und dann kann man
das denn abwägungen wird dann kann man
kompetenz demonstrieren und an das
durchdrücken
dann braucht man aber nicht erwarten
dass in anderen bereichen die man nicht
so gut kontrollieren kann weiterhin
kooperationsbereitschaft besteht das
sind immer die abwägungen das aus dem
vertrauten sicht wie würden sie denn
also vielleicht kann sie noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen wie man als politiker aus
dem stand ihrer sozialpsychologischen
forschung vertrauen tatsächlich bei den
bürgern hervorruft was sind also die ki
die kernpunkte also die kernpunkte sehen
wohl vor allem zeigen indem ich verstehe
dass die bedürfnisse verschiedener
menschen sind und das immer wieder man
kann da nicht über kommunizieren dass
immer wieder sagen und immer wieder
sagen wenn interessen gegeneinander
stehen wie habe ich den kompromiss
gemacht
das hat die kanzlerin heute glaube ich
ganz gut gemacht dann muss ich integer
sein ich muss sagen was hat geklappt das
hat nicht geklappt
da wurden heute einige und auch am
dienstag einige die chemie nicht
angesprochen die offensichtlich nicht
gesagt haben ja das büro der bahn ab da
ist also ein bisschen vorbeigeschrammt
da ist nicht klar will ich denn
evaluieren ob das überhaupt funktioniert
oder nicht das war von vornherein nicht
vorgesehen
da kann man sich fragen ob das eine
ernst gemeinte lösung war bei den
nebensachen da da ging es zwar viele
produktionen aber letzte
die umsetzung die den über 80-jährigen
durch die stadt fahren sollen um auf der
anderen seite in der halle zu gehen sich
impfen zu lassen
das muss unter umständen so sein aber
das muss ich wirklich erklären und ich
muss zeigen dass sie verstanden haben
dass das ein problem ist das heißt immer
dann wenn es vage wird wird es schwierig
weil dann die menschen halt nicht mehr
genau wissen was eigentlich passiert
genau wenn ich werde sobald ich wage
werde sobald ich abstrakte therme
verwendet dann verliere ich kompetenz
und integrität
jetzt hoffe ich dass wir niemanden mit
den abstrakten termini kompetenz und
integrität vertrieben haben aber dann
würde doch so ein satz wie von jens
spahn wir werden uns in einigen monaten
viel verzeihen müssen würde dann doch
von ihnen wahrscheinlich eine gute note
kriegen oder das geld genau das ist es
und das hat die frau merkel heute auch
noch mal gesagt natürlich machen wir
nicht alles richtig und es ist
tagesgeschäft und ich bin ja auch immer
so ein bisschen überrascht wenn hier so
bundeseinheitliche regelungen gefordert
werden ich sehe auf der einen seite dass
die gerechtigkeits wahrnehmungen da ein
thema ist aber wenn ich sage dass ich
sehr viel über lokale ereignisse und die
wir uns kümmern müssen
dann muss es möglich sein dass es lokal
reagieren und das ist ein bisschen
aufwendiger das darzustellen das ist
nicht so einfach und mag ich
darzustellen aber das muss möglich sein
um langfristig vertrauen so auch also
mehr erklären mehr kommunizieren vor
allem differenzierter kommunizieren und
fehler eingestehen das sind so die
kernpunkte die sie weitergeben und raten
würden herr kurz nach vielen dank für
ihre ausführungen und das sind uns diese
bundespressekonferenz analysiert haben
und euch vielen dank fürs dran bleiben
fürs zuschauen für das fragenstellen
sehr gerne wieder immer wieder hier wenn
ihr lust habt gut auch mal vorbei auf
zdf.de holt euch jetzt hätte er wollte
app da gibt es immer leute wenn wir
online gehen
wir sind immer da um eure fragen zu
beantworten zu wichtigen themen und wir
wollen uns auch wenn ihr uns like und
ein abo da last auf den entsprechenden
plattform wo auch immer ihr geradezu
gesehen habt jetzt sage ich habe erst
mal vielen dank macht euch noch einen
schönen tag bis bald und tschüss
[Musik]